hey guys I'm Erik Bosse and now that
Game of Thrones Season 6 went out with a
bang Phillip and I have been chatting
about where things might be headed in
the future so I'm gonna take us through
some of the predictions for what we
might see in season 7 so the creators of
the show of said that there are probably
only 13 episodes left in this whole
series so all that big payoff that's
been happening recently that's probably
gonna continue next season there's just
no more time for these slow burn
episodes where characters gradually move
around like pawns on a chessboard just
to build up to one big episode where
everyone dies which is great we're gonna
get a lot more payoff but the downside
is is that the creator's have also said
that next season is going to air later
in the year 2017 and I'll get to why
that's the case
in a bit but it gives us plenty of time
to think about all this stuff and
remember all my predictions are just
some preliminary theories based off of
where season six left us off and what
parts from the books that the show might
still want to use and obviously big
spoiler alert for everything I'm about
to say we've gone into all kinds of
theories in these videos and they're all
pretty much as educated guesses but a
lot of them turned out to be right so
just a warning if you wanted to go into
the rest of the series blind so I'm
gonna start things off with a big
overarching prediction for these final
two seasons so there are two major
conflicts that the show still has to
resolve man versus man and man versus
nature man versus man is the Game of
Thrones at the heart of the show who
gets the Iron Throne the jockeying of
power between the main families now man
versus nature is the existential threat
that's been looming since the series
cold-open I should say the very cold
open the White Walkers the man versus
man conflict is already wrapping up
several bloodlines have been wiped out
now and whoever's left has been unified
in two major divisions in the East we
have Daenerys Targaryen the Greyjoy's
Tyrells Martel's
all the Dothraki hordes Tyrion Lannister
and Varys in the north we have the
Starks all the other northern families
the wildlings Knights of the Vale and
Littlefinger caught in the middle of
these two forces is Cersei on the Iron
Throne which I don't think anyone thinks
will last very long so I predict that in
season seven we'll see the conclusion of
the Wars of men whatever happens to the
Iron Throne whether someone gets it or
it gets destroyed and no one gets it
that will all be decided in season 8
which is the final season I think that
will conclude the war for Men for
mankind
distance in westeros with an epic
showdown between the men united against
the night king and the White Walkers so
I'm going to get into some more detail
about how I think all this will go down
starting next season but for now let's
move on to Jon Snow
so our breakdown at the season finale
went into all the details about the
reveal of Jon's real parents Lana stark
and rhaegar targaryen
and what his birth name might be but one
question that we still had was will Jon
ever learn this secret my prediction is
yes Jon been revealed as the son of our
Targaryen and not Ned Stark but great
some major tension between Jon and his
new northern alliance we know no king
but a king in the north whose name is
stark I don't care if he's a busted that
starts blood runs through his veins and
it may cause Sansa to act on that
jealousy that Littlefinger planted in
her but how will Jon find out here's
where the guesswork comes in the only
people who know about Jon's lineage are
brand
Meera maybe if bran told her about what
he saw in the vision and Mira's father
Howland Reed who was with Ned Stark on
the day when he found John is a baby now
the obvious answer is that bran will
just make it back to Winterfell and tell
John the truth but I feel like the show
might go in another direction on this
one so my out on a limb prediction is
that Littlefinger will leak this secret
now why would he do that well if you
remember back in season five when
Littlefinger and Sansa we're talking
about Leanna in the crypt Littlefinger
totally looked like he knew more than he
was letting on check it out and then he
kidnapped and raped
so if Littlefinger does know this secret
revealing the truth would be an
interesting power move for him he could
use it to manipulate Sansa's jealousy
over John just telling her yeah you know
you should be jealous that John got
credit for winning the battle the
bastards when you were the one to save
the day and now they're calling him
takuna to norv because of supposedly Ned
Stark's blood runs through his veins
well guess what that's not true either
so I could be totally wrong about
Littlefinger but I think it would be an
interesting next step for him another
prediction I want to make about John is
I think we're gonna learn a lot more
about his father Rhaegar Targaryen next
season some people were confused by that
tower of joy scene and I don't know how
they thought this but they thought that
John's parents were Ned in Liana
oof but one of the reasons for this
confusion I think is that the show
focused a lot more on Liana to set up
this reveal way less so than they did on
Rhaegar season 6 showed us Liana and
flashbacks a few times and Winterfell in
the Tower of joy but Rhaegar Targaryen
remains one of the only major figures
from recent Westeros history that we've
never seen played on the show now I
think this is intentional and the show
wants to save John's Targaryen bloodline
for next season that's because the
implications of his father's side are
way more complicated than his mother's
side and the show wants to deal with
that separately so not only is Jon
related to Daenerys now he's her nephew
technically if Rhaegar and Lyanna were
married when the time he was conceived
he has a legitimate claim to the Iron
Throne now I don't think he wants the
Iron Throne but it's looking like half
of Westeros now considers Jon Snow to be
their King pretty soon I think we're
gonna see the other half of Westeros
looking to another Targaryen Daenerys as
their ruler I have a more on this theory
that'll come back to in a bit but for
now let's move on to the Mad Queen okay
so let's be honest it's barely a
prediction to say that Cersei isn't
gonna be a queen for long she's totally
isolated herself and everyone hates her
even Jamie and there's no way everything
she's done at this point doesn't bite
her in the ass so instead let's talk
about how Cersei leaves the Iron Throne
by the looks of that final shot in the
season finale Daenerys is totally gonna
sack King's Landing torch the place and
take the Iron Throne by force that would
definitely complete the prophecy of
another younger more beautiful to cast
you down and take all you all dear
but also remember brands vision back in
Episode six we saw that image of a
dragon's shadow flying over the roofs of
King's Landing and considering the other
images that were from that vision
we're a big events that hadn't happened
yet like the wildfire in the tunnels I'm
betting this dragon shadow is something
that hasn't happened yet and we'll see
it next season but there's another
vision I want to remind you about so
remember back in season two in the house
of the undying when Daenerys and her
vision walked into the Great Hall of
King's Landing with the roof caved in
and snow covering everything in that
vision the Iron Throne already seemed
empty like it was empty before Daenerys
even got there so while I think Daenerys
might be the one to conquer the city of
King's Landing I'm not sure that she
will be the one personally to physically
unseat Cersei so the smart money seems
to be on Janey being the one to kill
Cersei this is the queen Slayer theory
that look of fear and contempt that
Jaime gave Cersei as she sat on the Iron
Throne makes me think that Jaime wishes
he had been there to stop this mad Queen
from using wild fire to burn part of the
city just like he did with the Mad King
when you're in the name Kingslayer but I
get the feeling that Cersei isn't even
done with wildfire all the wildfire
reserves beneath the great Sept of
Baelor were blown up but remember the
Mad King also stored wildfire beneath
the Red Keep and it might still be down
there so when Daenerys is fleet arrives
next season I could see the Mad Queen
trying to use wildfire again and Jaime
moving in to stop her at whatever cost
now in the books there's even more to
this theory and it has to do with that
prophecy that Cersei heard as a young
girl
Cersei was told that she would die at
the hand of her Valon car which is high
Valyrian for a younger brother book
Cersei is paranoid that this means
Tyrion will kill her but remember Jaime
is younger than Cersei too if only by a
few minutes
well let's assume that neither Jamie nor
Daenerys will kill Cersei and that
someone else will step in to do the job
and my animal in prediction is Arya
Stark now I know it seems impossible
that I could get close enough but hey we
just saw her sneak into the twins
undercover and murder a high Lord and
two of his sons so it's clear the show
once Arya to cross the rest of the names
off her list and what name is at the top
of that list
now it could be that the younger and
more beautiful person from the prophesy
to cast down Cersei is aria
of course I still think that the younger
more beautiful person is Daenerys and
that Jaime will be the one to do the
deed you could say that he's younger and
more beautiful too I guess he's a pretty
boy but I'm just saying I think Arya is
going to surprise this next season okay
real quick you'll notice that I just dug
into an extended version of Circe's
prophecy from the books and even though
the general story of the show is moved
beyond the books it's clear that they're
still adapting old details in new
interesting ways for example arias for a
pie a similar event happens in a dance
with dragons and it was really cool to
have known the books and to see how the
show changed it and in my opinion
improved on it I think we're gonna see
even more stuff in the books find its
way into the show and if you want to get
a heads up on this stuff I can't
recommend reading the books enough and
actually a really great way to catch up
on the entire Song of Ice and Fire
series is to use audible they're doing a
special promotion for us where if you
sign up today you can get a free
audiobook with a 30 day trial just go to
audible.com slash new rock stars now
when we were preparing for season six
Phillip use audible to listen to all the
audiobooks and he got me hooked on it
too it was just an awesome way to remind
myself and get caught up on the
background of the show there's just a
ton of insight and subplots and theories
that you're really missing out on if you
just watch the show so even if you've
read the books you can relisting to them
and catch stuff that you missed before
and you can start right now with book 1
a game of Thrones by George RR martin
you can even use our audible code it's
new rock stars
just click the link audible.com slash
new rock stars ok let's get back to more
predictions so I talked before about how
Daenerys is clearly on her way to
Westeros ready to take the Iron Throne
by force but how close is she the
creators of the show confirmed that her
fleet is still in slavers Bay so before
she lands ashore in Westeros she still
has a lot of blue to cover and that
means that one thing I definitely think
we're gonna see you next season is a
clash between Daenerys his fleet and the
fleet of euron greyjoy
remember back in episode 5 of this
season the show left off your own
promising to build a thousand ships to
chase down Yara and Theon and then to
woo Daenerys by giving her his big talk
that's the last time we saw him that
loose thread has to be tied up at some
point and remember what was the exact
next shot that we saw after you're on
with the sea behind him
daenerys with the Dothraki sea behind
her I think those two parallel shots
were foreshadowing the naval collision
course that these two characters are on
but while we're on this subject the
season finale also left us with a
question of which Lord and Westeros
Daenerys will marry to form her
alliances she told Tyrion that she was
worried that she would never truly love
anyone and from the sound of it marrying
for love isn't really something that
Daenerys seems interested in do you know
what frightens me
I said farewell to a man who loves me
and I felt nothing remember she married
his star back in Mereen but that was
purely a political marriage to try to
broker a peace with the former slave
masters and to keep a perceived enemy
under her thumb so this idea of Daenerys
wanting to marry for political reasons
brings me back to that prediction I was
making earlier about John now if these
two Targaryen end up being the two most
popular rulers in Westeros and both of
them have supported claims to the iron
throne I'm gonna go out there and
predict that the two of them will rule
the Iron Throne jointly through marriage
now I know that's kind of weird
they're related but think about it
Targaryen were totally cool with incest
and there's a history of husband-wife
Targaryen couples ruling Westeros as a
duo also the show is pretty much
normalized incest and the people who
misread the Tower of joy scene were like
oh it's dark bang the sister whatever
that's Game of Thrones for you but
besides all of that it's totally in line
with who these characters are I don't
see a John Daenerys marriage as a sexual
romantic one Tywin Lannister and other
characters have taught us that marriage
in the Game of Thrones world isn't about
love it's about politics in the balance
of power you'll marry ser Loras I will
not please heir to Highgarden Tyrion
will secure the North you will secure
the reach no I won't do it that you will
and it's also one way to win wars that's
pretty much how Tywin won the war of the
five kings remember he promised the
Tyrells that their daughter Margaery
could marry Joffrey and they gave him an
army in return to save King's Landing
and ultimately win the war so similarly
this would be another political marriage
between a king and a queen to save the
realm from certain destruction and for
John marrying his aunt Daenerys would
unify both parts of Westeros leading all
of mankind together through their
marriage would deliver on the promise of
a song of ice and fire from the title of
series so even though I think the war
with the White Walkers be more in the
final season I still think we're gonna
see more of the White Walkers next
season too
the season finale made a big deal to
point out how winter is here and one of
the reasons that next season is being
delayed is that the creators of the show
want to wait so that they can shoot the
scenes in winter weather so even those
scenes that take place in lush green
locations I feel like they want it all
to be gray and covered in snow for
season seven and remember one of the
theories I talked about in my breakdown
for episode 5 is that winter itself is
brought on by the White Walkers the long
night didn't exist before the children
of the forest created the White Walkers
as weapons of mass destruction in the
war with the first men
so if winter has come to Westeros it's
because the White Walkers are the ones
bringing it we've also mentioned in past
breakdowns that brandsmart from the
night King allows the White Walkers to
break magical barriers to follow him and
that if bran travels south of the wall
the White Walkers might be able to cross
that magical barrier too but I'm gonna
call it here I predict that by the end
of season 7 we're gonna see the White
Walkers tear down that wall
in fact I'll go as far to say that it
will be the closing image of the season
because how else do you top that another
shot of dragons uh-huh if season 6 ended
by delivering on the promise of Daenerys
finally returning to Westeros opening
the gates of Westeros from the south
season 7 I think we'll end with a
parallel shot of the North gates
crashing open also I don't think it was
a coincidence that the new king in the
north last words to the current Lord
Commander the Nights Watch were do look
at them look good I feel like that was
foreshadowing and we're definitely gonna
see that line come back and our
previously on game of Thrones montage so
keep your eye out for it let's move on
let's talk about Arya so I already
mentioned my out-there prediction for
Arya and Cersei and in the last
breakdown Philip talked about how Arya
might run into the Brotherhood without
banners and hound and Melisandre since
they're all kind of in the same general
vicinity now and she may get a chance to
cross those names off her list as well
also a lot of people are saying that
Arya might finally reunite with her
long-lost direwolf gnam area but I'm not
so sure it's gonna go down that way in
the show next season the show is never
really focused on the starts connection
with their dire wolves as much as the
books do like in the books Arya works in
tune Ameria in her dream
beam's and that hasn't happened in the
show at all however just like the show
adapted The Fray pie event in two areas
storyline I think we might see another
ventral storyline from the books make it
into Aria story in the show and I should
say this is a spoiler for anyone who
still wants to read the books but this
characters been talked about so much
online that I don't really know how I
can avoid her at this point Lady
Stoneheart and I won't go into her
identity too much but in the books she
leads the Brotherhood without banners to
get revenge on the Lannisters in the
phrase and to generally spread terror
across the river lands so even though
the show doesn't look like they'll be
featuring Lady Stoneheart
I predict that they'll reassign that
killing spree to Aria next season now
what does this mean for aria the problem
with aria is revenge plot is that it's a
little short-sighted for her like what
happens when she kills everyone on her
list what does she do then
Aria story is based entirely within the
man versus man conflict I was talked
about earlier
she doesn't care or even know about the
White Walkers or the wars to come so
I'll make another bold prediction I
think next season will show the
completion of Aria zark and her death
now how will she die Aria has defied the
odds and survived tons of near-death
experiences so my guess is that she'll
die on her own terms maybe a suicide
mission to deliver that final kill again
these are all just shots in the dark but
we have 13 episodes left people
characters we love have to start dying
at some point all men must die so I'm
gonna wrap this up with a few quick
predictions about characters I haven't
gotten to yet
so Tyrion seems to have completed his
arc as the new hand of the Queen he's
found his rightful place as an heiress
his right-hand man we've talked in the
past about the theory that Tyrion might
also be a Targaryen check out our other
breakdown for more details on that I'm
kind of on a fence about it just
honestly because the idea of the dragon
has three heads those heads being
Daenerys and John and then Tyrion that
was more of a big deal from the books
and it's been in the show but I think it
could happen the only thing is we have
13 episodes left so if they're gonna
reveal Tyrion Targaryen lineage they
really need to good move on like chop
chop guys but two minor predictions I'm
comfortable making about Tyrion for next
season or reunion with his siblings and
with bran and finally hearing the end of
that punchline from the joke about a
jackass and a honeycomb and a brothel
I once brought a jackass and a honeycomb
into a brothel
once walked into a brothel with the
honeycomb and a jackass the madam says
what happened next we've heard it twice
rule of threes guys let's hear at the
end of that joke and then Brehon the
last time we saw brie and she was rowing
away from Riverrun with Podrick and
while the presumption is that she's
headed back north to Winterfell to
return to Sansa side I predict that the
show will use another chapter from the
books and get Brienne into more trouble
so spoiler alert again here at the end
of a feast for crows the last time Riaan
appears in the books so far she gets
captured by the Brotherhood without
banners and they accused her of serving
the Lannisters because remember she's
carrying Jaime Lannister sword
Oathkeeper they make Brienne choose
either kill Jaime Lannister or hang so
my prediction is we're gonna see this or
some version of this in the show
remember bran still in the Riverlands
maybe not too far from the Brotherhood
in the Hound after that enduring goodbye
wave between Jaime and Brienne at the
end of episode 8 it'd be interesting to
see Brienne confront her own love for
Jaime it would also be cool to see the
Hound in a position to spare the life of
a former adversary that he might have
some respect for and finally Jorah
Mormont was last seen riding away from
Daenerys seeking a cure for his
greyscale and my prediction is that his
search will lead him to the place where
all the great healers of Westeros
learned their art and the center of all
knowledge in Westeros the Citadel that's
where Sam and Gilly currently are and
it's here where I predict that the real
comeback against the White Walkers will
begin Philip mentioned this briefly in
the last break down but remember Sam
stole his family Larian steel sword
hearts pain and I think the show did
that for a dramatic reason remember
Joris father also owned a Valyrian steel
sword Longclaw which he gave to jon snow
after Jorah was outcast from his family
and i predict that these two outcasts
sons Jorah and sam will be the ones to
crack the code of how to create Valyrian
steel the art long forgotten in Westeros
and they'll use that knowledge to arm
the men of Westeros in the war to come
against the White Walkers in the final
season okay that's it thanks for
watching and let me know what you think
of my predictions I'm sure we'll end up
wrong about at least some of them we got
more game of Thrones Theory videos in
the works so even though it'll be a
while before we get new episodes of the
show we'll try to have you covered if
you haven't already go back and watch
our breakdowns from the past 10
so it's from season six there's a ton of
good stuff in there and if you like this
video please share it around subscribe
to new rockstars get the word out about
us that's one way to help grow this
channel in another way you can help is
by contributing to our patreon it's been
a huge help for helping us get these
videos out and the more people who
contribute the more you'll see this
channel grow big shout-out by the way to
patreon contributors Gil Pritchard you
rock Jill thank you so much and thanks
of course to everyone who's contributed
so far to our patreon we love you guys
you can follow the new rock stars on
twitter at new rockstars for updates
about when our videos will be coming out
you can also hit me up on twitter at EA
boss with any predictions or Theory
questions you might have you can do the
same with Phillip at fimo on Twitter or
on Facebook at facebook.com slash fimo
nose okay thanks again guys bye